[Music]
I was just wondering if you had any
advice on how to make blending a family
a little bit easier the first month was
so hard I kind of went in with the
attitude of I'm going to fix this all it
did was fix or it made me go crazy
[Music]
yes what up what up this is John with
the Dr John delone
show greatest show that has ever
existed I got to stop saying that cuz
it's not true there's I listen to a
couple of podcasts over the weekend I
was like man this is way better than my
show but on this show we do we're pretty
good and we talk about mental health
emotional health your marriage parenting
um dealing with kids in schools your
nutritional whatever you got going on in
your life your nutrition your sleep
whatever you got going on in your life
for two decades I've been been sitting
with people when the wheels have falling
off when they've been struggling and
we've decided to make it public for the
last few years instead of having these
conversations behind closed doors um in
hospitals in homes when someone's passed
away or somebody has packed up and moved
out we're having these conversations
here live and we have a brave group of
callers who call in with real things
that they're going through and we talk
about them here if you want to be on the
show if you're one of the one of the
brave brave few give us a buzz at 18446
93 3291 it's 1844 693 3291 or go to John
dooney.com
ask and don't forget like us and follow
us on social media don't forget to
subscribe on YouTube channel um or you
know do the thumbs up I don't know how
you like stuff anymore put hearts on it
just tattoo the show logo on your on
your on your neck that'd be kind of
that's that's what Kelly did and I'm not
going to lie it's pretty gangster move
she's got enough she's got enough powder
and and makeup to like conceal her
conceal everything but I I was proud of
you when you did that because you got
all these 80s metal bands and weird rap
groups and old boyfriends tattooed all
over you but you never put the show on
there and finally did it it was huge
money like it lets me know as a producer
like you're all in and I appreciate you
being all in and hey we're getting close
to when this publishes it's just a
couple of days before Christmas right
and we're getting close Christmas I love
it and it's my daughter's birthdays
around there so I love all that but it's
getting up on my favorite time of the
year absolute favorite time of the year
which is New Year's when all of the
world goes ah let's just try again and I
just love it I love everybody gets a
mulligan so we've got the questions for
humans New Year's deck of cards it's not
too late order those and this give yall
something to do over New Year except
more than just like drink beer and be
like hey let's blow up some stuff in the
sky or sit around and talk about how
it's all coming down maybe it's all
coming down but talking about it's not
going to help it so here's some cards um
that we've created specifically for a
group of people hanging around at New
Year's all right let's pull some out all
right first one let's do it how has it
been obvious this year that you have
zero control in your
life well number one she's looking at me
right now and that's you I have no
control in my life I have two powerful
women I report to you and my wife other
than that
um I think it's been the opposite I
think this year more so than any year I
can remember I have continually been
reminded of
how um on a on a micro level how in
control of things I can be when it comes
to what I eat uh when it comes to my
stress levels when it comes to exercise
and those kind of things macro level
when it comes to war and hatred and and
bigotry and people who just simply don't
understand how Economics work and the
country I live in borrowing I got zero
control right so I would say at the
macro level I have literally no no
control I can't control anything about
that the micro level I have infinitely
more control than I've ever felt what
about you oh this was a big one for me
this year because um so you know coming
up on one year lost mom house flooded
Christmas Eve lost my mother-in-law this
year
and it just it felt like um a lot of
things we were out of our house for 7
months a lot of things were Stripped
Away to the point where I had to just
let it go because um if I tried to
control I mean all these things that I
and I you know we talked about this
before I love control and but all these
things that were so out of my control
that I had no way to fix or to make
happen and I was just kind of it was
like I was just the only word to only
way for me to go was to God because
there was just no other option because
otherwise I was going to go insane and
so this year has really taught me that
there's a lot that I don't have control
over big things that aren't mind to
control and I need to let them go
because he's going to he's going to make
it work he's going to bring it around
he's going to redeem it it's just out of
my control so there's that idea like the
I've watched you and you've handled it
with Grace so much um you've been extra
mean a few times but that's fair um but
you like I've seen this year more so and
it may be just the magnitude of it all
that when you have like some pretty big
things it feels like you're controlling
them even though you're not but like
when your house explodes and people you
love pass away and personal challeng
like it's that leaf in the river
metaphor like at some point I can
continue to try to swim upstream and I'm
going to
drown or I can just do the right things
as this thing heads wherever it's going
to go right because what else are you
going to do exactly the only other
option was just to be drive myself so
insane and I tried to do that especially
with the house stuff trying to
micromanage everything and I just
thought you know I can't I can't live
like this yeah and um yeah it but I've
always felt God tried to teach me that
and sometimes he has to do it a little
harsher because you don't lert hey yeah
hey okay cool what's another one all
right the next one what's one thing you
want to stop doing next
year that's a good question you go first
um I no uh
you couldn't
function no one thing I want to stop
doing next year is um I'm really bad
about when it comes to my weight loss
which I'm working on five pounds down
very happy about that way to go um or
workout or whatever I I tend to get
paralysis by analysis you know the idea
of I need to know exactly what to do I
can't I need to know which thing to do
and what workout am I supposed to do and
how many days am I supposed to do it so
I don't do anything until I have all
those questions answered
and this morning I got up later than I
wanted to so I didn't have time to do my
workout and I was actually so I just did
like a 15minute yoga thing and I was
like just do something just move and uh
she said actually I've never done this
yoga with this particular woman before
on on YouTube and her she said pick one
word and I want you to think about it
and my word was start just do something
something go for a walk go if you don't
you know if you don't want to do that
just do something because anything's
better than nothing and really bad about
that about I have to have all the
answers first yeah well dude that's
awesome so that's something I'm working
on what about you um I've got two one
is man I like this has been like a a
major issue and so I'm really working
hard on it um beginning like recently
actually is complaining I complain about
everything just whne I'm I I am a
professional wher and that might
surprise people um who listen to the
show don't hang out with me regularly
but I'm always whing about something and
it just has to end it's so un endearing
and it makes it hard to like want to be
around somebody who whines all the time
just complains so that's um number one
um the second one
is
um really leaning back into contentment
like uh really like dropping my
shoulders and being really grateful for
more where I'm at and I can get really
big not on um
not on not being ambitious career-wise
because I like I I just I've been a
teacher since I was a little kid and
like to help folk like that's going to
be wir that's wired into me but this
idea like I want to do this so that I
can get this and so then I can get this
and so it's not being complacent or
settled in curiosity and those kind of
things but it's using those things to
try to get more crap and that's been
probably the heaviest thing this year is
just stop this insane pursuit of
accumulation and cool things are going
to come but I made a list this weekend
um I actually listen to Dr AA had a
podcast that released um talking about a
doctor um who's in Syria a missionary
doctor the guy owns two
T-shirts and he had been gone for a long
time and and in Scrubs that's what he
lives in scrubs and t-shirts and um uh
two T-shirts and he came back to New
York for some fundraising stuff and he
said it was just like wow he said the
food was great and whatever they're
talking about in the culture they don't
they don't they have a word for food and
it's food so when you say like what'd
you eat last night they're like uh food
because there's not this endless variety
and I was struck by there's virtually
zero suicide virtually zero heart
metabolic issues and I thought man I
think I'm I'm burying myself in early
grave through complaining and through
always trying to get the next thing and
so those are two things I'm going to
really work hard on through with
meditation with intentional practice
with those kind of things catching
myself getting a group of people being
like you're complaining again um I think
those are two things that I'm going to
work on stopping this year yeah and they
both go I mean they're they're so Hand
inand yeah you know it's when you stop
doing one and start doing the other they
just they I think it's almost an
automatic one stops one starts yeah
complaining and whining is I'm not I
want my way right now and my way is
about contentment yeah yeah yeah instead
of seeing the
insane like glitch in The Matrix we all
live in right it's silly it's silly cool
awesome man so pick up your questions
for humans go to john.com you can pick
them up that's the um the New Year's
deck man you pulled some great questions
all right let's go out to Baton rou and
talk to uh Baton Rouge and talk to
Heather what's up
Heather hey Dr John thank you so much
for taking my call I'm doing okay I
wanted to tell you first of all just how
much my husband and I both just
appreciate you and all the work that
you're doing I finished your book
building a non-anxious life last night
actually and um it's it's been helping
me so much and so thank you for that and
thank you um yes so I'm hoping um yeah
I'm choosing freedom and with that I'm
going to go into my question and all
right let's do it hopefully um you can
yeah help me out all right so um my
question is how do I love and respect my
parents and other extended family
members while setting boundaries to
protect my marriage and my
children and um to give you some
background I can um just talk about a
recent event that happened when we were
visiting my family recently yeah go for
it um all right
so
um so we fac we faced these issues
several times once when we visit my
family but became a little more obvious
this time with my dad um he tends to
be just usually annoyed with our kids
when we're there like by the noise they
make the messes they make he speaks in a
belittling and condescending way not
just to my children but he's always
spoken that way to my mom and um to us
as kids and um um many people so that
that's an issue that's seems to be
getting worse and then my mom um doesn't
always agree with our parenting Styles
and thinks we should just turn on the TV
anytime the kids are getting Ry and we
really try to limit screen time and my
husband and I felt led to become
Catholic this year so that's something
that we're kind of on a journey on and
so we take like prayer and going to
church very seriously and when we get
our kids up in the morning when we're
there to go to church she gets upset by
the fact that we're not spending time
with them that we're going to
church and then um the last last um
relationship that we kind of deal with
when we're there is my sister and her
kids um she kind of gives her kids full
access to phones internet and her kids
are a little bit older than ours and
they're learning about my 9-year-old
niece has already learned about like
what sex is and um so we have kids that
are much younger and so we're just
trying to um protect them and feels like
when when we go we're kind of just
having to constantly kind of monitor our
kids and protect them from things that
are happening around their house so just
hoping that you can give me some
guidance on how I can how we can still
build a relationship with them but like
how to set boundaries with them yeah you
bet um all right so there's a couple
things here um one just off top of my
head nine-year-old should know about
sex um that should be an ongoing
conversation uh but they should not find
out about it via their cell phones or
the internet they should find out about
that from trusting adults in their life
so that's just an aside um all right
so I think we've got love and respect
all sideways okay love and respect
requires as a fundamental core Principle
as a as a building block a Cornerstone
of love and respect is boundaries love
and respect does not mean that you have
to to do whatever somebody else wants of
you okay yeah so if you grew up in a
home where you're always
belittled and your dad flexed on the
people that he was supposed to
love that meant that y'all's job was to
curate a world where Dad was never his
feathers were never
ruffled because he was a peacock who
liked to really shine and kick up those
tail feathers so the goal of the house
Mom you your siblings the goal was to
keep the peace right yes exactly okay
Mom has been putting up with this for
what 25 30 years how old are you uh I'm
33 they've been married for 40 years
okay so for 40 years her job every day
is to make sure he's not pissed
off that's how she stayed safe that's
how she stayed quote unquote out of
trouble that's how she manufactured a
little pocket of safety inside of her
world okay so let's set that over to the
side for a
second often when people grow up in that
I mean are are in a relationship like
that they um look to the next lowest
person on the rung if you will and they
extract that
similarly but they often do it from the
bottom up not the top down here's what I
mean your dad is huge he comes over the
top he's a big loud male and he may be 5
foot2 I don't know how big he is but
he's got this presence that is I can't
tell those kids to be quiet or he
doesn't say anything that way he can
kind of uh act indignant when somebody
calls him on it but he gets all tense
and he goes around huffing and puffing
and picking up the the toys that the
kids left out really heavy right um yeah
or he goes sh real loud like he's just
real abrasive mom on the other hand
is Oh you mean you're just going to go
to church and we're just not going to
have breakfast okay I guess I'll just I
guess we'll just Eat Here by ourselves
then um if that's more important to you
then um okay it's the same exact move
just underneath the boat she's dragging
it underneath it instead of on top of it
is that ring a bell yes yes it is okay
so that is one person who has been using
the other person to get the life he
wants not as a partnership but as a
basically a um an extended parent
and then your mom does that to the next
lowest person which is her kids
okay so everything is about peace and
everything's about comfort and what you
and your husband have chosen to do is to
do something opposite to head into a
relationship with your kids which is
messy and hard it is easy to dump them
in front of a TV you know why how I know
that I did it last night yeah my wife
and my son were out at a at a church
event my daughter was chaos and I needed
to finish some stuff and I said hey you
know what I know it's a school night do
you want to go watch a show and her eyes
lit up and she was like oh my gosh dude
she ran up there you know what I got
done in that 30 minutes I got so much
done
and it wasn't that big of a deal on a
one-off but if that was my default every
day all the time I'd be failing my kid
right y'all have chosen to not do that
you have chosen to head into it how old
are your
kids 6 three and two okay you know what
6 three and two year olds are
loud yeah and running around and chaotic
and they break things and they test
things and they're curious and they hit
their head on things and they don't put
things away that doesn't mean that y'all
are failing that doesn't mean that means
y'all are growing kids that H are using
the whole world as a laboratory for how
things work and how things feel right
yes and your parents are opting out of
that
world you also have chosen to not give
your kids unac unfettered access to the
internet y chosen not to let them be
raised by screens your sister's not made
that choice and so she's opting out of
their
life here's what this
means I cannot love and respect somebody
if every time I'm around them I'm on
defense or I'm slowly being
suffocated okay
so the best way I can love and respect
somebody is to have clear and firm and
loving
boundaries that doesn't mean avoidance I
think we have used the word as avoidance
is I can never be in contact with you
and I think that's an overreaction
particularly by younger Generations I
don't think we have to do that but I'll
go hang out with you and I want to be
really clear hey if you say that joke
about these people I'm I don't want to
be around it I'm gonna leave and then
they'll make the joke and you'll go all
right hey guys y'all take it easy I'm
out are you you serious yeah yeah I was
pretty clear about that that's just I
don't think it's funny I'm out you'll
have a good one guys and I I'll catch
youall next time and I'll come back
those are my friends those are my family
members and I'm going to be clear again
hey just FYI and if they do it again
then what they're saying is we don't
want you here we would rather tell this
joke about this group of people than
have you here that's what they're
saying yeah I found out that there's a
group of my friends who I love who have
different jokes when I'm around than
when I'm not and you know what I
freaking love that because that is so
respectful of my
boundaries you know what I'm saying yeah
so similarly I think it's worth a very
direct and a very loving conversation
you're 33 years old you have three kids
how long have you been
married nine and a half years almost a
decade you know what it's time for
grown-up conversations with
grown-ups yeah that's a coffee taking
your dad out to Coffee hey Dad can I
take you out to coffee
sure hey Dad every time my kids come
over to your house it's going to be a
hard
conversation everything about your body
language tells me you don't want us here
and you don't want them here that
somehow you think I'm failing as a
parent and I actually think I'm a pretty
good parent and my kids are
great but you belittle us you talk down
to us you get mad at us and here's the
thing I want them to have you in their
life but I can't have
that me saying that to you you imagining
yourself having that conversation what
does it feel
like uh it doesn't feel comfortable it
I've I haven't had a conversation about
this exact thing but I I have had
conversations when I bring things up to
my dad in the past and it it doesn't go
well okay he he plays it down he turns
it back on me and doesn't doesn't listen
do you have that in the moment or off to
the side like in a pre prearranged
time uh I can remember specifically one
time in college when I like specifically
just pulled him off to the side when he
was reading or something and tried to
have a conversation with him and okay
well I my recommendation is to try it
again just and this is why you you want
to know that you entered into an
uncomfortable situation and you retained
your dignity and you treated everybody
with love and respect
respect and I think love and respect
often requires
discomfort and honesty and Clarity if
you just disappear and decide to not go
I think that can be
cruel and end you end up becoming just
like
him and instead of belittling him to his
face like he does to you you belittle
him under the water he sucks I don't
want him around our kids we're not going
to go anywhere where now I have a rule
that I only talk if somebody is going to
hear me I don't speak just spoken that's
what the social media world is that's
politicians um I don't speak if I if I
can't be heard and so if you think in
your in your guts dude he can't hear a
word I'm saying and cool don't have that
conversation and same with your mom I
think it's worth taking Mom out for a
coffee and saying hey
Mom we have drawn a line when it comes
to
screens we're just not going to do it
it's not how we're going to raise our
kids it's not and so I want that to stop
being an expectation in this house and I
understand if our kids are too loud then
we're just going to we're just going to
not have them here we're going to not
have them here and we're going to roll
out but all that to say is whatever your
boundaries happen happen to be the way
you demonstrate that you love and
respect your parents is by being very
clear kind respectful if Poss I mean
always respectful but kind if possible
have the clear conversation and then
they get to respond however they want to
immature like you said turn it back on
you blame
you and my God how how heartbreaking and
lame it is for a child to sit down with
their parent and say hey here's how I
experience you and for them to make it
their kids's fault so ridiculous and I
hate that that happened to you I hope it
didn't happen
again your sister's kids are handing out
phones and your nine-year-olds talking
about sex with a six-year-old and you're
not comfortable then dude then don't
have him around cool have maybe have the
conversation with your sister sister hey
tell your 9-year-old to stop talking
about sex with us with our with my kids
please have that conversation are you
kidding me yeah I'm I'm I mean no I'm
not kidding that's a big deal to me and
here's the deal they may all opt out of
relationship with you for a season that
will hurt so
bad but kind of like surgery to get out
the cancer get out a tumor they have to
cut you they have to cause you pain hurt
your body if you will to get out the bad
stuff if your family opts out it will
hurt but it will also be removing a
group of people who say they love you on
one hand and spit on your boundaries and
values in the
other so it's going to hurt it's going
to be painful you're going have to
grieve it and puts an end to this
madness or what I think's going to
happen is as a 33-year-old who's been
married for a decade with three young
kids they might hear you and I would
start the conversation like this this is
really hard for me I'm scared to have
this conversation I'm nervous about it
so I'm going to Fumble through it a
little
bit but I'm going to ask that you please
treat me as an adult as I as we talk
through
this I know that's Pie in the Sky for
some of you listening you're just
laughing you're like dude my dad would
never hear that call but I think it
would shock you how many parents would
be honored pain hurt but honored to be
approached that way by their adult kids
most people want to be connecting most
of the time they just don't know how and
if you have this conversation and give
give your parents a road map at least
you're giving them a chance thank you so
so much for the call Heather I'm really
really grateful for you we'll be right
back hey guys it's deloney listen as the
holidays get closer and things get more
chaotic and finances get tighter and
family members get louder and louder
opinions about
everything you can find peace with
hallow the number one Christian Prayer
app in the world and even if you're not
Christian I promise you'll find Value in
stopping slowing down and praying to a
higher power listening to the prayers
spoken by other people Hall has
thousands of Christmas and Advent
prayers and meditations plus incredible
peaceful holiday music to help you
de-stress some of the music I even
listen to while I'm lifting in my garage
you can join in Hallow's pre 25
challenge with daily devotions based on
the writings of CS Lewis meditate with
scripture read by Jonathan roomy from
the TV show chosen or wind down to a
Christmas Bible story so find your sense
of calm and peace and get hallow free
for three months at hall.com
dealone that's three months free at
hall.com
delony all right we're back and this
one's going to be a doozy I could
already I can already tell this is a
married couple on the
line oh boy let's go out to Mike Mike
Mike Mike Mike in Oklahoma what's up
dude I'm doing good how are you I don't
know man I just I see the
line Jenna gave me a line of what this
call is about and then she just said oh
yeah his wife's on and I'm like oh this
is gonna be okay and you're asking for
this right I'm asking for it oh geez
okay all right um so let's uh bring on
your wife Tara cool yep y's bring her on
oh geez are you all in the same house
right now uh we're actually uh outside
my mother-in-law's House in Colorado uh
we're sitting in separate cars right now
so so y'all are having this conversation
at your mother-in-law's house yeah all
right while I'm talking to her I want
you to download an app called hotels.com
because you may need it all right and I
have no affiliation with him I just know
they got lots of hotels all right let's
bring on Tara what's up t- money hey how
are you I'm probably better than y'all
are about to be what's
up uh no we knew we already knew what we
were getting ourselves into so I think
you're spot on with the intro oh boy all
right let's do this all right so Mike
I'm gonna do something a little bit
different all right yeah okay so here
I'm just going to read
you what the by line is that Jenna has
put in my Monitor okay okay and then
I'll let you tell the story all right
and Tara and Mike is have you all talked
about everything are we sure we talked
about everything all right here we here
we go let's dance so it says underneath
Mike from Edmund Oklahoma in my Monitor
it says wife and I have been working
through infidelity on my part she's
pregnant now struggling with our I'm
struggling Mike struggling with our lack
of sex life is that correct correct sure
wish she wasn't on the phone all right
let's do this dude let's do it all right
walk me through it Mike
all right so um so basically our story
is um infidelity on my part uh it's been
two and a half years since our since my
confession uh we've been in therapy a
recovery groups we're part of a very
strong Community uh uh we actually
co-lead a marriage group of other
couples that are restoring their
marriages after infidelity and U and
pornography addiction um tera's actually
in her second trimester we had a
miscarriage back in May
and basically um yeah we're we're just
struggling with our sexual intimacy um
after after the infidelity after the
miscarriage um and I actually feel
selfish you know I feel really selfish
for even wanting to have sex with her
since she's not feeling well during her
pregnancy um this is something we've
talked about and we just we uh we need
help in this area Okay cool so uh great
job that was like you really concise and
you kind of put it all out there so I'm
proud of you um and I saw heard a lot of
reflection in there it wasn't a lot of
well this happened and this happened you
took a lot of ownership there so that's
awesome Tera what's your what's your
side of the
story um well that's we have done a lot
of work just like he said I mean we have
you know after something is Earth
shattering as infidelity um you have to
you have to start from ground zero and
that's what we've done I mean we have
literally I mean there was nothing left
after that and we have like you said
gone to years years of therapy we still
go we have these accountability groups
so the the communication and the
transparency like we talk about
everything like there's no se you know
so like we do have like a really good
foundation I know we're only two and a
half almost three years into after
infidelity but we've made a lot of
progress so my it's just that like
infidelity has I mean not infidelity um
like intimacy has always been a
challenge just his upbringing of like
you know abuse as a child starting
around five and then um you know
introduction to pornography starting at
so that's kind of where his journey
started and then mine was like the
opposite like I didn't have like touch
for my parents like hugs and kisses and
so I could just like live the rest of my
life and like not be touched probably
and be totally fine so you could see how
it was like an explosion waiting to
happen when we got married right but
yeah so we just um R to the infidelity
and we continue to and then when we got
pregnant in May um and we lost that baby
I mean it was really really hard because
we never thought that we would be
married much less have another child and
then when we lost that baby um you know
it's it's really really hard and then
now that I'm pregnant again it's like
the trauma from like not only the trauma
from losing the baby like pregnancy
after loss is one thing but then you add
in um you know all the stuff with the
infidelity kind of came out once our
daughter was just born so there's kind
of like that impending like okay are we
going to do this again once we have
another baby and then there's the fear
of losing the baby and then I've just
been really really sick on top of it all
um so it's just like this like triple
edged sword it feels like I'm like if I
don't have sex with him like I might
throw up on you but you know it's like I
I don't it's like our intimacy is it's
you know what I mean it's like a really
big deal for us because if we don't have
intimacy for months at a time like is he
going to spiral again back into this you
know this this hole that he's dug
himself out of so it's just like super
complex okay so it it's super complex
and we can pull some pretty clean
strings on it okay and level things out
a bit is that cool yeah um I know yall
have both been to counseling I'm going
to bypass probably a year of therapy
okay and kind of cut to the some the
chase on some things just to make this
like that way it's not like a five hour
call um and I'd love it as y'all
continue I'd love to have you back on
almost recurring and we can kind of walk
through what this looks like if y'all
are ever interested in that okay oh sure
yeah yeah I'm
interested
so I'm getting to a place where I wrote
a whole book on trauma right and and and
where you go from here and the
importance of our childhood stories I
think those stories are really important
to peel back and uncover right
and I think the challenge remains is
whether I'm working with people in
marginalized communities I spent my
whole career doing that I don't talk
about that on the show cuz I I don't
want ever that I don't want other
people's marginalization to be how I
move my career forward right but I spent
20 years doing that I've sat with people
who lost everything everything I've sat
with people like you guys whose marriage
is an ash and you're deciding are we
going to do this or we going to like
whatever what are we doing next right
but every single time I've sat with
somebody and they're sitting in the
trauma we always land on this one core
question what are we going to do
now and two and a half almost 3 years
removed from the affair infidelity right
uh or multiple Affairs or whatever it
happened to
be I want to really challenge y'all to
to not go back to well when he was five
he experienced this and I didn't have
touch and so I experienced this because
where we are now is you both committed
to being in a marriage that's here right
now right right and so those stories
might play into what our nervous system
responds the way it does with those GPS
pins I talk about all the time right it
it might light me up or it might do this
or do this but every day I have a choice
as to what this day is going to look
like
period And I might have to practice for
as much as a decade to turn the corner
on some things but I am here now okay
right so I want to I want to honor and
know that those pastor are there but I
want to spend the bulk of my energy in
the present moving forward is that cool
does that make sense yeah yeah
definitely okay so in in real quick
terms when you're like h i don't want
sex I don't want it to be touched like I
don't feel good I haven't gone to the
bathroom in eight weeks and I feel like
I'm going to throw up every day and oh
my gosh and I just feel all bloaty and
gross and my parents didn't even I want
that part to be done does that make
sense I want to live where we are right
now because here's why when we live in
the right now you have to take ownership
of what happens next it can't go back to
well they did this and that goes the
same for you too
Mike like it's not weird you're not
broken and I'm applaud you for saying it
out loud I want to have sex with my wife
a
lot and I would prefer to have sex and
her not b on me that makes it weird
right yeah and we don't talk about this
enough men don't talk about this enough
I don't know that I don't know many guys
um outside of some sort of pathology who
wants to have what I would call duty sex
or chore
sex right like here she just get getting
off sex like well she's sick and grow
feeling gross and pregnant but she's
going to take one for the team like like
I don't know many guys who enjoy that no
right here here so Mike here's what I
want to get at with you and I'm sure
you've been through some of this with
counseling and I'm gonna man I could do
a whole five five week episode five
weeks of this on the show men have been
funneled into this world where sex is
the only form of intimacy that is
acceptable that's okay that's the only
tool we have and you compile you stack
that on top of your childhood which your
nervous system was wired with
pornography into it mhm like um
Sensational sex performed by
professionals right right that's how
you're you grew up and you have
childhood abuse sexual abuse or physical
abuse what what did you experience as a
kid yeah um just a lot of uh other just
other kids around my age just a little
bit older um pretty much making me
engage in sexual acts with other kids
there you go okay all right surprisingly
common and surprisingly frustrating and
disturbing right so both it all at the
same
time can I go one step deeper with you
both on the phone yep yeah okay please
Mike sometimes the layer beneath the I
want to have sex is I don't really I
love I love deeply I would die for but I
don't like my
wife I don't like her conversations I
don't like the interactions I don't like
how she's always complaining about me I
don't like that she doesn't desire me
the same way I desire
her and pornography solves that problem
instantly a woman at work who laughs at
my jokes and only sees a curated version
of myself who thinks my text emojis are
hilarious that works until it blows up
everything right or here's another one
right Mike has created a world how long
have you'all been married eight years
eight years how many kids one one okay
Mike has a world where he's got a a one
child didn't really understand the depth
and gravity and feelings and emotions
around a miscarriage I talk to Men Who
feel it as deep or deeper than their
wives and I talk to men who are like I
don't get it like my wife is sobbing and
I don't know what to do and everything I
do is wrong because it's not bothering
me the same right and because everybody
Grieves different and what you do to
control yourself during those seasons is
you just shut the machine
down you build a life where you feel
completely
dead you go to autopilot and autopilot
keeps you off pornography autopilot
keeps you out of another affair
autopilot also keeps you out of trouble
because you're not saying the right
things after a miscarriage autopilot
keeps you out of I don't really
understand what this little kid running
around here doing and I just know that
my wife's telling me I'm doing it wrong
all the
time okay MH and so we create a world
where SE is the only time we feel
alive that's it it's the only time I can
get my heart rate up past you know 75
beats a minute is if I'm having
sex and so here's why I tell you that a
lot of the conversations about I want to
have sex I want to have sex I want to
have sex has to do with the life we've
created for
ourselves okay and sex everything my
feeling alive getting my heartbeat up I
don't have any hobbies I feel like I'm
failing at my house I feel like I like
my wife I feel like she doesn't like me
all of that gets dumped on one slide on
a on a on a water slide at a water park
and it's well let's just do it let's
just have
sex and if I can increasingly push the
boundaries while we're having sex and go
to this position or this thing or this
weird after eight years you kind of
start pushing the boundaries on most
everything we've tried it or we've
thought about it or I'm trying to get
her to read my mind and do some things
that she like what right all of it
and then you have that one person that
you run into and she already knows all
and she brings it up and you're like oh
my right so these things happen
supernaturally I mean not supernaturally
like Superman but like it's just a
natural progression here what I want
youall to begin to ask yourself is what
does our intimacy and desire look like
outside of having
sex have yall heard me talk about the
gas pedals and
brakes um I don't think I have okay I
want y'all to order a book by Emily
nagaty called come as you are Co M as
you are the um the cover of the book
you're going to get it and go you can't
be serious I'm serious that get that
book and I want you all to order it I
want you to read it together okay it's a
book for women about women's sexuality
but it's been incredibly instructive to
men who I've asked to read it myself
included here's where it's so important
it talks about the myth of a sex drive
it's not real it's not a thing we've
been taught that women have sex drive
light to men it's not
true sex and intimacy is this series of
gas pedals and
brakes what does that mean that means I
want to create a world where there are
as few breaks as possible and as many
slammed on gas pedals as
possible Mike it may stun you to find
out that a dishes in the sink are are a
break to your wife she doesn't know why
you don't know why you just know that
when you're like hey let's have sex
let's have sex she's like well I got to
go clean the kitchen you hear that as
she would rather have a clean kitchen
than be with
me yeah right yeah what she's dealing
with is 200 years of feminine baggage
about what your house is supposed to
look like if you actually love your
husband and so for her I can't even be
in the moment knowing that I'm failing
him out there in the kitchen with with
dishes in the sink I'm making that up
I'm just inventing that right right I
cannot have sex with you until bedtime
is done
perfectly and you're thinking we just
lock the door let's party
right yeah and so what I've seen um Dr
nagy's book is is extraordinary but what
I've seen and heard all across the
country is couples backing out of the
bedroom
conversation and by the way there is a
moment we got to put sex on the calendar
we have to um can we hold hands one
night can we do the um John delone
erotic envelope system um where you put
five things in an envelope and she puts
five things in an envelope and we just
commit over the next month we're going
to pull one of these things out a week
or one of these things out twice a week
or one of these things out every two
weeks and one of them may just be
holding hands and Mike you're going to
go son of a
right and it might be in the morning you
pull pull it out and Tara it's
um Regular boring married sex then you
know okay Mike here's what here's all
the breaks I've got going for
me laundry the dishes the this the that
the thought of
you um looking at pornography again our
Netflix history which I stumbled on and
saw that you were watching
whatever these are all breaks for me
and Mike goes cool I got it what else
right so we're going to have the brakes
and gas pedals conversation and gas
pedals what are things that turn me
on what are the things that turned me
on I don't want to get too detailed into
my house but last night I cleaned the
kitchen up I put all of the rags like
the dirty rags I put them in the washer
and washed and dried
them and I emptied the dishwasher after
the after stuff was done I cleaned it I
just went around and and it wasn't to
try to have sacks it was
I now know what my wife walks in the
door and she her shoulders drop and
she's like ah
amazing see what I'm saying we're
creating a world and and her vice versa
with me um here's the last thing Mike
you're not broken for wanting
sex while you're married you're just
not and Tara your body is not yours
anymore you share it and how old's your
little
one uh our daughter just turned four my
gosh yeah
yeah so your body's a jungle gym and it
has been for the last four years yeah
yeah you're dealing with pregnancy loss
yeah you're having that every day every
every time you have gas every time your
heartbeat accelerates a little bit every
time you get a weird movement you're
like oh is this it is this it is this it
right am I right yeah okay yeah you Mike
you don't understand how much Tara is
not breathing during the day holding her
breath absolutely right absolutely and
Tara we we could talk talk about sex I
don't think you know how much Mike loves
you yeah in a crazy way and I think the
only way Mike has been given permission
by himself and his upbringing and his
culture is I can demonstrate that by
having sex with you or going and make a
lot of
money yeah and would would I be right to
say Tara there's a whole bunch of other
things that serve as breaks in your mind
and in
reality oh yeah
can you give me two of them real quick
uh I mean you were spot on I was
laughing when you were talking about
like dishes and like like literally like
the dogs Bowl being filled up with food
you know just like the smallest things I
know it sounds crazy but it's just like
one less thing I have to do and worry
about so you were just spot on with all
of the breaks you were talking about
like I I resonate with those so I want
you guys to go out and have a date and I
want you to spend a week thinking about
here are the things that really turn me
on and here are the things not to turn
me off like bad breath or right you're
like you haven't showered not like that
turn me off but prohibit me keep me from
getting in the mood okay okay and I want
youall to write those down and what
you're going to do is give each other a
road map to each
other okay and that's different than hey
can we have can we like start with oral
sex and then go to regular sex and then
move that's that's that's peripheral
you'll get to those spots but before
that what if we created a world
that I walk in and my shoulders drop and
then we can say you up for it tonight
you want to party and she's like I'll
party or we can party but I'm gonna barf
on you and Mike is like that's a risk
I'm willing to take right
right but Tara imagine a world where you
go to put your four-year-old down and
you get done singing the song and you
come out and the diss taken care of and
the dog's taken care of and Mike the
whole time you're like I've been working
all day bust I don't who gives a crap
this is about creating a world for your
wife and Mike you're honest
about here's the things that turn me on
a text message in the morning a morning
hug uh sexy text messages throughout the
day uh and maybe ter you got to put text
reminders on your calendar whatever I
don't whatever it is but let's let's
work through creating a world outside of
the
bedroom and I've just heard it over and
over and over and over and over that
often the bedroom issues begin to
magically not magically very practically
transform
themselves we'll link to the book in the
show notes but I want you two guys to
pick it up today buy that's your
Christmas present to yourselves read
that book all the way through and it's
going to be eye opening for you Tara who
grew up in a no touch no discussion home
and Mike you are going to get a Humanity
behind the pornography that you consumed
since you were five in a way that you
probably have never imagined never
imagined go check it out thank you all
for calling hey call back anytime I'd
love to have yall on if youall try this
out you'll have the breakes and gas
pedal conversation and it fails
spectacularly call me back and have me
on the and and I'll have you on the show
and we'll talk through it or if it
starts working and slowly leaning in the
right direction I'd love to have that
conversation too and we can get more
more concrete examples about sex we can
go on whatever Avenue you want to go to
but I love that you are having the
question and man talk about an amazing
example of what life after infidelity
can look like two people who said let's
rebuild the whole thing from the floor
up we'll be right
back if you've listened to my show any
amount of time you've definitely heard
me talk about Thorne Thorn is an
incredible supplement company that makes
what I think are the best supplements in
the game I've taken thorn for years way
before I had a show as you've probably
heard from listening to other podcasts
or just walking through a local corner
store there are a million different
supplements all claiming they the next
great thing for all sorts of ailments
almost all of those claims and products
are either lying not good products are
just a waste of your money Thorn is one
of the very few supplement companies
that make Pure Clean tested and backed
by science supplements no fluff no
gimmicks no nonsense Thorn is what I
take personally and it's what I give to
my kids and make no mistake supplements
of this quality cost more than the
nonsense you see in gas stations so I've
partnered with Thorne for an incredible
25% off discount for our Delon show
listeners go to thorne.com
slou delone choose what you want add it
to your cart create an account and when
you check out 25% off will be knocked
off of the entire order and here's the
best part that discount sticks around
for Life go to thorne.com slthe letter
/one check it
out all right let's go out to Utah and
talk to Chrissy what's up
Chrissy Hi how are you Dr John partan
what are you up to oh you know just
living Another Day in
Paradise very cool Lehi Utah that's
where Paradise
happens I I don't know I just moved here
over the summer so I'm still trying to
convince myself that's true oh you just
moved there this summer
yeah all right so you went through
summer in one of the most beautiful
places in the
world and you're about to go through
winter yeah I think it's a whopping 25
degrees outside so I went on a hunting
trip winter I went on a hunting trip out
in that area in February and of last
year of I guess earli this year and when
I called and said hey what how cold is
it going to
be guy goes
eight yeah this sounds pretty pretty
accurate yeah that was from a Texas boy
that was not cool all right so what's up
how can I help um so just to give a
little context uh the reason why I moved
to Utah actually is I got married in
July and me and my husband have Blended
families he has three boys or not three
boys three kids from his previous
marriage and I have one so now we have
three boys and one girl all together how
old um the oldest is 10 uh the next one
will be nine next month mine just turned
eight and our youngest is six oh good oh
man amazing yall should start saving for
college that's gonna be a rough few
years okay so
10986 okay yep all right and I was just
wondering if you had any advice on how
to make blending a family a little bit
easier if that makes sense because
everyone talks about it but but I don't
know if anyone really knows what's
happening other than their outside
perspective yeah give me
um where do things stand right now y'all
are about six months in where do things
stand um it has gotten better the first
month was so hard yes and I just felt
like no matter what I did I was failing
these kids cuz uh me and my husband got
divorced over um similar situations and
so his ex-wife kind of dropped out of
the picture leaving Behind these three
beautiful kids and then my ex-husband
was kind of emotionally abusive not to
my son but just to me and so I just feel
like there's a ton of baggage going into
this relationship right correct I kind
of went in with the attitude of I'm
gonna fix this no it did was or it made
me go crazy is the lesson I've learned
in that often when we we say the words
I'm going to fix this what we our bodies
do instinctively is we hold on
tighter oh yes and the opposite has to
be true and I'll walk you through why
and there's there's a lot of
Neuroscience here and a lot of nervous
system work like Dr pores I mean a lot
here I'm gonna paint it as simple as I
can make it okay okay and let's go ahead
and be honest and call out what you said
at the very beginning I haven't had a
blended family so I'm only speaking from
what the literature says what my
colleagues say and what my friends
who've tried
it have reported okay so I'm still
speaking as an outsider I think it's
important to call out there okay right
all right so you have a 10 a nine an
eight and a
six-year-old three boys and a girl
tossed in there right yes sir I said
that like sand lot and a girl right but
you've got three boys and a girl right
okay so I want you to keep a couple of
words in mind always always always this
will be for you and your husband okay
stability stability
stability routine
predictability things that they can
count on everything in their world has
fallen down but we often think of
falling down like a house
collapsing that's not what fell here the
house did fall but what crumbled is the
foundation the sidewalk that they walk
on everything they know and a lot of
times you and your husband are adults
yall can quickly get on a new footing
kids
cannot they absorb the footing from the
adults in their
life and so what we often do when when
people blend families is they spend a
lot of time on the house part whose room
what's the decorations let's do fun
things and when what the kids need is
routine routine
predictability stability stability
stability that often means that Mom and
Dad have to go to counseling to regulate
their nervous system to learn how to
have
peace because the kids are absorbing
every every ounce of energy you're
putting out into the world okay so
everything I'm going to tell you going
forward is Guided by one word stability
how can me and my husband create
stability and predictability now he
might be an over the road trucker he may
travel a lot you may travel a lot you
may be on call cuz you're a nurse or
what that's all fine but there is a
routine to oh Mom just got called out so
here's what we do my kids and my wife I
travel a lot I'm always on the road and
my my wife and kid and Kids when dad's
gone here's what we eat here's how we do
bedtime it's it's it's their own little
world they've created it's amazing but
it's it's stability stability okay
that's the next one so here's the next
one I want you to consider
outbursts are simply unregulated bodies
trying to
adjust so what does that mean expect
anger expect the opposite which is
insane compliance Uber compliance which
is a trauma response too
sometimes explain you're not I mean
expect you're not my mom I don't want to
be here I hate you go back to wherever
it is you came from Mom I hate these
boys
why do we have a girl here all that is
is a 10 a nine an eight and a
six-year-old's bodies trying to make
sense of new
oxygen okay they're not
asses they're they're
kids right and what we do is we take the
words they say and the tone they use and
we we um transport it to adulthood and
if an adult talked to us that way they'd
be an
ass right these are
9-year-olds sixy olds okay their bodies
are simply trying to adjust that doesn't
mean we don't let them we we let them
run wild they're not feral but that
means we don't hold them to adult
standards yet because they're kids and
everything in their world has been blown
up
okay right so imagine um okay well I'll
just go to the next one go very slow
this is the next one and by the way
we're going to clip this and uh if
possible clip it and we're going to send
it to you right away in its raw unedited
form that way you guys can have this
right away we'll have to wait a month
for it to come out okay so you didn't
have to take notes you can just we can
just talk I want you to go very slow a
lot of like you're like six months we
should have this thing together their
whole that's exactly how I feel their
whole world
exploded right okay it
exploded your your new boys their mom
said I don't want
y'all
right which would crush anybody anybody
but that's not just a psychological
crushing that's not because when I say
psychological crushing you can't just go
yeah but I'm here that's not how that
works it destroyed their heart their
heart rhythms their nervous system
right your daughter grew up in a home
where Mom was not
safe she has absorbed how to navigate a
potentially like volcanic
man that's in her
body and so she's gonna have to learn
what a loving guy looks
like and feels like it's just gonna take
time okay okay so go slow here's the
next one never ever ever ever talk bad
about their
parents right for sure you know that but
I just want to reiterate they know that
half of them is you and half of them is
their dad or half of them is your new
husband half of them is the mom that
left right and so if it's like well your
mom did
this right right it's a sideways dis on
the kids it's not a sideways it's a it's
a hammer to their head it's crushing
it's a yes it's crushing to a child
that's why these divorces that that are
so contentious where kids are used as as
collateral is I mean you're just you're
ruining a hundred years of lineage when
you do that if not more oh for sure it's
just abusive and that's kind of it is
and that's kind of what made me decide
to get married again is a couple years
ago I think my son was maybe six at the
time and I can't remember what even
happened but I got him back from his dad
and um his dad just said something kind
of snarky and rude and I was like H he's
such a butthead every time and we got
home and my son could tell just like you
said he just absorbed my
emotions right into his soul and was
like what's wrong mommy and I was like
oh I'm just annoyed with
Daddy and it was such an AA moment for
me that I was like my son doesn't
deserve to be my emotional support
animal I can't do that to him good for
you and husband doesn't get that anymore
he left he left he didn't get that
anymore he doesn't deserve that nope
your new husband does he can annoy the
crap out of you old husband he cashed
out right right if you go to if you take
all your money withdraw from the bank
and you deposit in a new bank that old
bank doesn't get to tell you what to do
with your money anymore
period right okay all right so let's go
to the next one real quick um I want you
all to create a who we are
board W you go to Michaels or um uh a
Hobby Lobby something like that and get
a
canvas and I want youall to get music
the kids get to pick the music and if
they're already Savvy enough they get to
pick the
playlist and you and your husband get to
add a few songs that are just ridiculous
songs that y'all love like like whatever
ridicul poison or Dwight yok like
whatever songs y'all grew up with just
ridiculous but we're going to create an
evening what um and I'm going to pretend
your last name is Smiths okay we're
gonna create a the Smith here's who we
are and we're gonna hang this somewhere
where everybody can see it and like the
delonis is we say yes to Adventures
Hospitality we treat each other with
dignity and respect and we're about to
redo it we did it when my daughter was
super super super young so she couldn't
participate we're about to do it again
but here's here's why that's so
important they now can have a touchstone
that they can see that they're a part of
something that is being built that is
new okay okay it's kind of like when
they're building a building they hang an
American flag out on on the big cranes
out there it's one of these things like
that's new and it's under this
Banner also when kid when one of the
when the 10-year-old smarts off to you
you're not my mom I hate you you point
back and say Hey The
Smiths treat each other with dignity and
respect and you're allowed to be
frustrated I get that you you ha cannot
talk to the adults in this house like
that that's not who we
are and then when they like you when you
violate one of the who we are one of our
core values you are op in out you are
choosing to leave okay and so like last
night my daughter had a thing with she
was acting in a certain way and I said
hey come here real quick and I brought
her real close and we were eye Lev I was
sitting down and she walked eye Lev and
I whispered into her ear so as not to
embarrass her I said hey if you talk
like that again you are choosing to
leave the room and we don't like it when
you're not with us we want you here
but you can choose to leave which is
different than me kicking her out hey
you can't talk to us get out go to your
room because then I've just I've just
done what their mom did I've just done
what their dad did I've showed them
there is a line that you can't cross
that if you cross it I don't love you
anymore you're out of my presence and my
kids I want them to learn at a very
young age I will never send you out of
my presence you can opt
out if you come into my house
intoxicated acting what you're telling
me I don't want to be here cuz that's
not who we are but you're going to hold
the keys as to whether you're in
relationship with me because your old
man will love you to the moon back and
I'll come get you wherever you are see
the difference
there I do that's that's a big
difference a huge thought of it that way
okay so expect them to be bananas expect
them to be jerky and expect them to look
at you and say are youall going to leave
too and and in fact I'm going to push
you to see if you
will and they're just opting out all
right here's the last thing I'll I'll
I'll throw with you I'll throw a couple
at you real quick um conversation
journals with each kid that works with
some kids some some not so much but
everybody gets a spiral on their
bed and they get to write in it and
you'll respond every night and put it
back on their bed when they're at
school oh that's cute and it's just a
way to especially with younger kids and
actually it's worked with teenagers who
won't talk to their parents but they
might just write today didn't suck so
bad today I was happy that's it that may
be all I put and you can write a
paragraph today I thought of you and I
started laughing because that thing you
said last night you're
hilarious I saw how hard you were
working at this thing and it just brings
me so much joy whatever like we're going
to have just this dialogue back and
forth again one or two of your kids will
be like this is stupid I'm not writing
this a couple of your kids will it'll
latch on to them
if you can intentional time with each
kid that's tough especially when they're
this young it's just hard it might be
five minutes on the front porch and it
might be you with a 10-year-old like no
no no we have tea time at night
everybody away we get seven minutes of
tea
time and we're just going to have an
evening glass cup of tea or an evening
ice cream whatever the thing is but we
have seven minutes nine minutes it
didn't have to be an hour right um
here's the last two if possible give the
other parent op opportunity to win with
the opposite kids what could that look
like what if you took two of the boys or
the three boys out to buy a Christmas
present for their
mom that sounds insane and you'd have to
be a super emotionally regulated adult
to do
that to admit your husband had a family
before y'all got together to admit that
these kids are still connected to their
mom even though their mom is doesn't
treat them with love and respect now
that may not work in your house
but give them an opportunity what you're
showing them not by by by your words but
by your actions I'm not at war with you
with your parents with your mom I want
her to win I want y'all to love
her and they stop feeling the sense of
disloyalty to her every time they're
nice to
you ah I and your your kids stop feeling
disloyal to their dad every time they're
nice to your new husband it's like no no
no on the same team if your husband took
your two kids out one uh six is is is
old I don't know what your son how old
your son is but hey we're going to buy a
cool present for your
dad this I mean that's like money in the
bank wow see what I'm saying and listen
your husband I mean your ex may talk
crap about your new husband he sucks
next year he sucks next year he sucks
your kids over time you're playing a 10
or 15E game they will get it they'll
slowly go oh I'm being raised by a man
who's very secure treats people with
dignity my dad is immature and rude and
ugly I don't want to be there I don't
feel safe in there
anymore see what I'm
saying yeah it's not an instant
gratification kind of G we hey once you
have once you're divorced and you have
kids instant gratification is over that
leads me to my last Point don't take
anything anything anything
personally so hard I can't think of
something
harder don't take it personally don't
take it personally how his ex-wife talks
about you she's not well that's okay
don't take it personal how your
ex-husband is threatened by this new
amazing Family Y are building from
scratch he opt it out don't take it
personally what a 10-year-old says to
you or when that 10-year-old becomes 14
I'm not going to take anything
personally I'm out I'm out I'm out the
only person who has permission to hurt
me personally is my husband my new
husband that's it andice for Versa kids
don't kids don't get that kind of vote
they can learn that hey you can't say
that it's disrespectful or you can say
I'm choosing to be hurt by what you said
but they're not going to hold the keys
to your kingdom like that cuz you're the
adult and you're the regulated one so
that's a lot I threw at you I hope that
helps um I wish you guys all the best
hey in surviving a Utah winter and
building an amazing amazing new blended
family takes time goes slow a lot there
you guys can do it and thank you so much
for your heart Chrissy all right we will
be right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at john.com
all right as we wrap up today's show the
song is called Rise and Fall by Daniel
renstrom a lot of the music on this
record is performed by the one only
James Childs if you're one of the OG 17
you'll remember as the original producer
on the show that he clearly did not have
a an alliance and Kelly destroyed him
he's no longer on the show
ha well formed well done Kelly song's
called Rise and Fall by Daniel renstrom
and it goes like this the dawn of the
light is breaking tonight at at the
birth of this dangerous boy as Shepherds
and Kings bow down bow down and sing at
the birth of this dangerous boy many
will rise and fall at the birth of this
King those who oppose stumble on this
stone at the birth of this dangerous
King but many will hear believing in
fear will hope in this dangerous King
this is actually a song about Kelly the
dangerous dangerous King hey I love you
guys have a good Christmas we'll be
right
[Music]
back